you know anybody almost anybody
these days with the technology that's
available to us can make a well produced
film of two people sitting in a table
talking and if you can find a way to
make that interesting
you might impress somebody and they
might say okay we're not going to give
you a 50 million dollars but here's
$200,000 go make three people sitting in
a room talking you know go make two
people sitting in a park talking go make
something that will you'll have a bit
better opportunity to show what you can
do and that's that's all I've done is
step by step I've made slightly better
and better bigger and bigger films and
it was because of those you know these
films I made for the asylum they were
technically they were mach busters i
mean i didn't think of them that way I'm
not trying to rip off other people's
movies that doesn't interest me in the
slightest and I'm not trying to satirize
them the idea of the Mach Buster from
the asylums playbook is not so much to
satirize the individual project but to
satirize the idea the two hundred
million dollars is required to make an
entertaining movie it's not and so for
200,000 or 350,000 I made a couple of
movies for them that were you know
incrementally bigger and better than the
independent film I'd made that got me
those jobs and it was the fact that I
had done one of these films for them
well I delivered the script that they
wanted I delivered it on time I was
relatively easy to work with during the
development process I don't know if the
director of development would agree with
me a hundred percent on that because you
know any creative people are going to
have clashes but in the end I remember
that they're the ones paying the bills
and they understand what they're
market is so I give them what they want
and then I go out and I make the best
film I possibly can on the money they
give me and I put together the best team
of people people who aren't going to say
oh it's only a $200,000 crappy asylum
mock buster they're going to say we're
gonna make this the best battleship
movie we can or the best alien planet
movie we can or the best zombie film we
can given the resources available to us
and it was the fact that I had done that
and delivered to them what they needed
and something that showed I actually
cared about the material and that I had
some intelligence and I had some style
it was that that made them come to me
and say we want you to write a movie
called shark storm and for me to be in a
position to say no why would I want to
write a movie called shark storm haven't
we had enough dumb shark movies and they
went away and said I will find somebody
else to do it and then a month later
they came back to me and they said what
we really want you to do is write a
movie called sharknado and I said that's
the most ridiculous thing I've ever
heard and if I can write it that way
then sure I'll do it I'd love to do it
and thank God they said yes it's okay to
be ridiculous on a movie called
sharknado you know and from there in the
last two years I've had some modicum of
success that hopefully now is leading to
bigger and better things
but it's all because step by step I
proved that I was I was reliable that I
could do what they needed me to do and I
only got that opportunity because I'd
done what I said I could do I went out I
raised the money I made this film and
instead of just saying take a chance on
me I said here this is what I can do and
I can do it for you
you